pendant la grande guerre la commune de
descartes a perdu une centaine de ses
enfants
un siècle plus tard la jeunesse leur
rend hommage 24 élèves de 3e du collège
rouget japon remettre en état ce
monument aux morts avant les cérémonies
du 11 novembre les élèves sont venus au
mois de septembre
étudier le monument aux morts donc son
architecture ses symboles et ensuite on
étudie les fiches de décès des poilus
d'écart toi mort entre 14 et 18 et les
élèves ont tout de suite remarqué que le
monument mais il aurait mérité un petit
rafraîchissement
voilà pour le sentiment il pensait que
c'était une bonne idée donc on a
contacté la mairie la mairie nous a
donné son accord et nous appuyer
justement dans cette dans cette démarche
et ils sont heureux de participer
c'est un devoir de respect de mémoire
pour eux qui n'ont pas connu ni de grand
père ni de l'arrière grand père pour la
plus part et c'est pour eux un événement
qui va sans doute marqué leur jeunesse
c'est quelque chose qui leur parle je
pense ça permet voilà de voir que
l'histoire c'est quelque chose de vivant
et là on sort du manuel pour venir voilà
touché de l'histoire je pense que c'est
ça qui leur plaît à en juger par
l'ardeur mise à la tâche les élèves
effectivement semble s'être totalement
impliqués dans cette opération et ont
bien intégré le sens du devoir de
mémoire c'est très importante parce que
ça peut aider la commune puis ça
commémore la la mémoire des soldats
morts pour la patrie en fait donc je
trouve ça très symbolique très important
or leur rend hommage et je trouve que
c'est ils sont battus pour la france
c'est des gens de deckard dont je sais
c'est honorable pour nous deux c'est
bien pour nous de montrer que là je fais
un conte est là pour les femmes
pour pour leur rendre hommage à des
cartes d'autres enfants seront
appliquées dans les commémorations de
dimanche prochain les élèves de cm2
cette fois des trois écoles primaires de
la commune